1619 project founder nicole hannah jones
has been denied
tenure at the university of north
carolina leftists are furious
squishes are worried and i for one could
not be happier because
academic freedom is for chumps it is a
hoax
as you can see very clearly from all of
our public debates
from transgenderism to the covid vaccine
i'm michael knowles this michael knowles
[Music]
show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from
21 jack jordan who writes unrelated but
today
my female teacher said that women get
raped for far more than men and
therefore it's ridiculous that men are
the ones
deciding how we fix that i decided to
raise my hand and said she was wrong if
you include prison population men
actually get raped more than women
she told me i should check my facts and
where in the world did you hear that so
i told her the bureau of
justicestatistics.gov
and she responded with we don't need to
talk about that i'm in high school and
i'm
already canceled wow this comment
actually ties in so well
to what we're talking about today which
is the idea of academic freedom which
the libs and the squishes are always
pushing
but which is just completely ridiculous
uh obviously your point was right on the
bureau of justice statistics
and also her point was wrong in that
just because someone experiences
something that does not mean that they
cannot have an opinion on it does not
mean that they
don't have faculties of reason and they
can't have something to offer
to the world you know gosh as the
censorship
increases as everyone's trying to find
out what you're saying and cancel you
for it
great great time to get expressvpn the
big tech monopoly
is opting for silencing us and for
censoring us
to fight back against big tech's control
of the internet i
use expressvpn when you use expressvpn
on your computer or on your phone
you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your ip address
that makes your activity much more
difficult to trace and sell to
advertisers but what's more
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your network
data
to protect you from eavesdroppers and
cybercriminals
what i like most is how easy it is to
use
okay it just takes one click boom done
you protect all your devices that is why
expressvpn is rated number one
by cnet and wired revoke big
tech's right to your data secure your
internet with a vpn that i trust and
that i use for online protection
visit expressvpn.com michael that is exp
or essvpn.com
michael to get three extra months free
with my exclusive link that is
expressvpn.com
michael right now to learn more i love
that nicole hannah jones this 1619
project
propagandist was denied tenure at unc
so the libs are furious because the libs
want this woman to push her propaganda
even more than
she already has let's not forget the
1619 project which is
based on a lie the entire thesis of the
1619 project
is that the american revolution was
fought to protect the institution of
slavery it's just not true
there is no evidence of this whatsoever
even left-wing academic historians shot
this down
the times persisted in error for seven
months but then even they corrected it
and it was kind of a
fake half correction where they just
added in these words some of they said
some of
the colonists fought the revolution for
this reason even that is bogus it's just
it the american revolution was not
fought
to protect the institution of slavery
that doesn't even make sense
slavery would not be abolished
throughout the west for quite some time
afterward and there
and there were people at the
constitutional convention and at the
continental congress who were fighting
against
slavery regardless we are now being told
by the would you call them libertarian
right or the squish right we're being
told that this is a grave threat
to academic freedom and i just
i just don't want to hear it anymore
this is what the libs do
they push some bogus idea and then for a
while the conservatives fight against it
and then we accept all of their premises
and then we start arguing their points
this is what happened with academic
freedom the modern conservative movement
the one that started after world war
ii began with william f buckley jr
publishing a book called god and man at
yale
the subtitle of which was called the at
the superstitions of academic freedom he
called it a hoax it's a joke
and it go it goes back much further than
that
academic freedom comes from the
university of leiden in 1575 it begins
after the protestant revolution
the university of leiden in the
netherlands decides that they're going
to have
academic freedom and yet even this first
university with total
you can say and think whatever you want
they refused to grant total academic
freedom then the protestant synod of
dort in 1618
restricted this even further because
they wanted to combat the armenian
heresy okay
keeping up so far then some german
universities tried to revive it for like
five minutes
napoleon shut that down then in 1636
harvard was founded in america was it
founded on academic freedom
no it was founded to quash the
antinomian heresy
these universities were founded with a
mission with a purpose they have to have
a mission
if you're going to teach anything you're
going to teach some things and you're
going to contradict other things
if you're going to teach the 2 plus 2
equals 4 you're not going to permit the
teaching the 2 plus 2 equals 5.
and this is not just true in mathematics
it's true throughout
the university 1940
you have the american association of
university professors this is
the we're talking about the height the
peak of academic freedom in america
right
they issue their statement on academic
freedom and tenure so this is the actual
professors these are the guys who are
fighting in the trenches for academic
freedom
and in their statement on academic
freedom they say that teachers have the
right to quote freedom in the classroom
in discussing their subject
but they quote should be careful not to
introduce into their teaching
controversial matter which has no
relation to their subject
and later they told them to exercise
appropriate restraint
so even the most out there full-on
endorsement of academic freedom says
teachers can't mouth off about their
stupid politics and they need to use
restraint
and they're obviously accountable to the
trustees and to the parents
and to the university administrators
obviously
and yet the the right somehow adopts
these terms even the
bill buckley's intellectual heirs the
people who call themselves buckleyites
and things like that who now are you
know they're writing for places like
i don't know the dispatch or something
you know these kind of
left-wing ostensibly right-wing outlets
uh
they'll endorse this they'll say yeah we
support academic freedom it's just
a joke debates take place within limits
okay
you see this very clearly if we get the
schools for a second you see this very
clearly
on the vaccine issue certain opinions
cannot be held in public there are just
there are just limits
on it there are just restraints and we
might not like that and we might want
the restraints to be different i
certainly do
but we have to acknowledge there are
limits to these debates
so on the vaccine issue a lot of people
don't want the vaccine that's something
like one in five americans
and a huge portion of them say they will
never get the vaccine under no
circumstances
now you've got multiple governors
governor of ohio governor of maryland
governor of new york
quovid are offering cash
prizes lottos for
people who get the vaccine you get the
vaccine you get entered in the lottery
maybe you can win millions of dollars
sort of undercuts the messaging here
right because the messaging is everybody
can't wait to get the vaccine oh it's so
wonderful there's no questions about it
whatsoever and that's why we're going to
pay people millions of dollars to do it
because of how because of how obvious a
choice it is to go get it no it
obviously some people have reservations
here but you are not
allowed to mention this a great example
of it
i was watching the view i wasn't really
watching the view i was watching clips
of the view
and there was a debate between megan
mccain republican
joy behar democrat and the debate was
over the vaccine and why some people are
not getting the vaccine right now
now listen to the debate listen to the
two sides of this
argument and see if you can suss out
what the differences are you know what
it's not that
complicated people it's not nuclear
physics all right all you have to do is
get the damn vaccine
when you go inside wear a mask even if
you have the vaccine there might be
variants around wear the damn vaccine
and then get the booster when that time
is coming
what is the complicated problem here
with people i don't understand it this
is just to own the libs
when i was a kid the polio vaccine was
available
and everybody was dying to get it if you
watch those kids on television and those
iron lungs that's what they used to show
us
a child and an iron lug and i was a
child and i'd be like oh my god i don't
want to be in there get me that shot
and of course people did it everybody's
getting it okay
you guys out there it's not you're not
owning the libs
by not getting the shot nobody's grown
an extra arm nobody's growing an extra
head everybody's fine it's the people
who are not taking it who are not fine
okay hold on so pause for a second here
before we get into meg inside of it
i know a lot of people who haven't taken
the vaccine and they're fine
and they're totally fine right
especially young people especially
people who are not really at risk from
this virus
they think look i'm not really at risk
statistically i'm at a very low risk of
this virus even if i get it i'm at very
low risk of any complications
so why would i get the vaccine well what
about with a polio vaccine right covid's
not polio
especially for young people polio very
dangerous for young people covet
just not that dangerous for young people
that's just the statistics of it
i'm not spreading any kooky conspiracy
theories some groups are at greater risk
than others it's not complicated people
wear the damn vaccine wait what what
does that mean
well what look people got the polio
vaccine come on what's so complicated
here's what's complicated
for the public health authorities had
far greater credibility when the polio
vaccine came out they've squandered
their credibility now they've lied to us
multiple times they've admitted they've
lied to us multiple times and even when
they haven't lied they've just made
predictions they've gotten the
predictions wrong
so pardon me if i don't rush to believe
them
when they say that something's totally
i'm not saying i'm i'm
never going to get the vaccine i'm not
saying that if i were 85 years old i
wouldn't get the vaccine
but obviously there there are reasons
that people are
hesitating here one-fifth of americans
who are not only interested in owning
the libs i love owning the libs it's a
great thing but there are other reasons
as well okay megan responds the
messaging is
absolute garbage coming from fauci and
it's not just about owning the libs the
demographics on who is vaccine hesitant
it crosses the gamut there's still a lot
of hesitancy in the african-american
community
i am a nurse i know who actually was
administering vaccines said that her
daughter wouldn't get it because she was
worried about
fertility issues this is something i
keep hearing a lot
that a lot of women are concerned about
what it could possibly do
if you're in child bearing years all the
women on the show i assume are
done having babies except possibly me
that's something that i would want to
know
i believe the science i believe it's
healthy i think they have come out
saying even pregnant women
can get this vaccine but the fact that
there hasn't been a
a summit or a discussion or figures that
people trust
on tv to try and help quell some of this
that's why the conspiracy theories keep
uh growing and spreading people just
don't understand and don't know and
i don't like to judge people who aren't
uh accessible to the same kind of
resources and education i am
but this is a serious serious problem in
this country
you know a lot of people i'd like to yes
a lot of people
um of color have every right to be
skeptical of
the government all right let's pause it
right there so megan mccain
makes the point yeah this is about more
than owning the libs and look some
especially women in their childbearing
years have these worries because of
stories that we've heard and these have
been
published right it's not just like a
friend of a friend of a friend said they
had some issues
these are things that have been written
about in in the popular press public
health officials
have discussed some of these things so
sure
so some worries beyond owning the libs
but then notice
megan says but i i trust the scientists
i trust the public health authorities
and it's a big problem that some people
are hesitant to get the vaccine
but black people in particular can have
a good reason to be worried about
getting the vaccine and then joy behar
comes in and she says well yes you're
right black people
are totally justified and hesitating
together vaccine white people are not
but black people totally are even though
it's the same vaccine it's the same
science we're all the same people no
black when black people hesitate to get
the vaccine that's totally great that's
awesome
and when white people hesitate that's
really bad
they agree they agree over the
fundamentals of the debate which is that
everyone should get the vaccine everyone
should trust the public health
authorities
when white people hesitate it's bad when
black people hesitate it's good
where's the debate i mean i don't mean
to be too harsh i think megan's raising
some good points here especially in the
first part of her answer
but in the fundamentals of the debate
you're not really allowed to disagree
and i don't think
i don't think on network television it
would be permitted for anybody
to disagree which is why it's important
to find alternative
channels not just in watching our
political debates but even in say
shopping for auto parts which is why you
should check out rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to these
sort of questions they'll say hey how
you doing auto parts guy and they'll say
hey is your honda a g3c
or an xql let's say i don't know man
come on it's kind of early how am i
supposed to know that and then they'll
say well okay then they go out they'll
do it they'll look
for the part they don't have it in the
back they'll order it online probably
from
rockauto.com and then they'll come back
and charge you twice as much don't do
that
don't do that that's an unpleasant
experience rockauto.com always offers
the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear
like you know some gimmicky companies do
okay why would you spend up to twice as
much
for the same parts rockauto.com is
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years i also
want to thank those of you
who have sent me in screenshots i talk
about how easy the rockauto.com website
is to navigate how
even i can do it and i've gotten
messages from people the screenshots of
how easy it is to navigate the website
so i'm glad i'm glad you're enjoying it
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and they're right knolls know w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
for months we were told that it is a
wacky kooky conspiracy theory to suggest
that the virus that was discovered 400
yards from the wuhan institute of
virology
the coronavirus associated with bats
discovered 400 yards from the place
where where chinese officials were
studying coronaviruses and bats
that's insane to suggest there's any
link right now on this show
right when the story came out right at
the very beginning of the epidemic
we pointed out huh that's a coincidence
huh would it
that's a little strange maybe we should
look into that we were told no this is a
kooky crazy conspiracy theory
politifact said no way this is
fake news this is great you can't
suggest that
now it's looking more and more like the
wuhan institute of virology
had something to do with the leak
there's a lot more evidence of this now
public health officials have changed
their tune they're saying okay after
after a year of doctor fought foucher
saying no way don't bother my friends
at the wuhan institute of virology that
people associated with me have been
working with for a long time even on
some of these issues
no no no don't worry about that
don't look over there well now now we
are paying attention to the man behind
the curtain
and it looks as though there might be a
connection jan saki was asked about this
at the white house
and her non-answer i think is the answer
house republicans are claiming that they
have significant
circumstantial evidence that covet 19
originated in a lab
has the white house seen any
circumstantial evidence that it did not
originate in a lab i will say that our
view continues to be that there needs to
be
an independent transparent investigation
and that needs to happen with the
cooperation and data provided
from the chinese government we don't
have enough information
at this point to make an assessment at
what point would
president biden call president xi and
say we've got
587 883 dead americans we're just trying
to figure out
if this happened if coven originated in
one of your labs
uh let us in well i would say that we
have made that call
publicly many times we have conveyed
that privately and we have certainly
communicated that
they were not transparent from the
beginning that's not acceptable
there's an opportunity now in the next
stage of this effort
for them to be transparent to
participate in international
investigation that can
bring a conclusion to the origins and
provide information that we
republicans democrats everyone in this
country would love to have access to
oh okay okay that's fine because
initially
you all said this was completely insane
now here
jen sackey actually made the point when
she opened up her answer she said look
well you can't disprove a negative and
she obviously misspoke and she sometimes
does
she want to say you can't prove a
negative but for a year
more now more than a year all these guys
said
the wuhan institute had nothing to do
with it they were trying to prove the
negative they said nope
had nothing to do with it saying well
now we're hearing people have evidence
that they did have something to do with
it do you have any evidence to the
contrary well no we need to look there
will be talks
and investigations and hey it's no big
deal i think it is a big deal
i think it is a big deal in no small
part forget about china for a second
forget about the ccp and the wuhan
institute
the same public health officials who
told us
don't wear masks masks don't work then
they said you have to wear masks masks
do work and then they told us
get the vaccine there's no problems
whatsoever and then they said well you
know if you get the vaccine there's this
clotting issue so we're gonna pause the
vaccine for a little bit but
okay now there's no problems again and
hey the wuhan institute had nothing to
do with it actually they might have had
something to do with it
we just don't trust them okay and it's
not our fault that we don't trust them
and it's not that we're conspiracy
theorists because we don't trust them
they have squandered their credibility
that's their problem
speaking of conspiracy theories
aliens have you been reading the
headlines
aliens are around they're afoot the uaps
which is the new term for ufo the
the army and the navy and the pentagon
are coming out and saying
they've got a lot of evidence of ufos
and it's all coming out now and there's
going to be a big report
from the pentagon the former head of the
pentagon's advanced aerospace threat
identification program
which is the defense department's ufo
program has said that he believes the
government is in possession of
mysterious exotic technology
a lot of people are talking about this i
had a little bit of a debate with my pal
matt walsh over this because he's
totally on board the alien train he says
yep
i'm i'm 100 there are aliens
i'm skeptical i'm not just skeptical
because it's it's a rather outlandish
claim
we haven't seen a ton of evidence of
this yet i'm not just skeptical because
it poses challenges for one's worldview
i'm skeptical because of the politics of
it all
the leaks that we are seeing about the
ufos
where are they coming from they're
coming from the federal government
they're coming from the federal agencies
they're cut the government
that we have been told is totally
infiltrated
by woke radicals who are opposed to our
traditional way of life
the the military that just aired an ad
about how
the their ideal soldier is a soccer
playing girl raised by lesbian mothers
or something
the the same defense apparatus
that the cia for instance just posted a
commercial saying that we need to you
know hire strong
intersectional feminist latino women
that's the ideal james bond now or
something
the the idea that these guys are just
accidentally dripping the ufo stuff
it strains credulity i think
i don't buy it i think this is
uh an intentional leak i think that
the propagandists in the federal
government know exactly what they're
doing
and i think it's a distraction i think
that there isn't i don't know
i'm not saying that's a grand conspiracy
i'm not i don't know what what is the
agenda i don't know what the agenda is
i'm just saying this sort of information
doesn't drip drab drip drab
out this kind of headline grabbing
sensationalism does not just
accidentally leak in this very steady
methodical way
from the federal government especially
the pentagon
on accident that's not what happened
there is a messaging plan here there is
a communications plan
this is how people run pr okay this is
how people run communications now what
is the point of it
i don't know i suspect it's to just grab
a lot of headlines and grab all of our
attention and get us all talking about
this perhaps so we're not talking about
other things
i don't know i don't know exactly what
the aim is but
i'm not taking the bait unless until i
see more evidence that they're you know
the ufos have landed and the martians
are running the government
uh i which i guess i might believe that
i might believe
that joe biden is actually just a sort
of you know
martian or something that would explain
a lot of his verbal faux pas but until i
see some evidence of that i'm not
i'm not taking the sensationalist debate
i want to focus more
on the mundane political matters at
speak here
talking about these foreign enemies of
ours either from
another universe or from right across
the ocean
compare the army ads this is this has
now gone viral
two army ads that are that are running
one out of russia
won the aforementioned lesbian woke
army add in the united states which
do you think represents a better
prepared
army going in the right direction
giant hulking muscular guy
big muscular guy gets out of bed
he's doing push-ups looks like a james
bond villain
jumping out of airplanes
got guns full of rounds
shooting at their enemies with a little
girl
raised by two moms oh my gosh i also
marched for equality oh my goodness
i like to think i've been defending
freedom from an early age
oh my goodness you marry my other mom
with such powerful role models i
finished high school at the top of my
class
and after meeting with an army recruiter
i found it
a way to prove my inner strength i'm us
army corporal emma malone lord
and i answered my call so if you're
walking down a back alleyway
somewhere at night and you see
the the russian guy with the guns with
the black rifles
which is going to be more intimidating
that guy or the little girl sort of
blushing on santa monica pierre talking
about how wonderful
her lesbian mothers are and how she's
been fighting for freedom her whole life
free presumably by freedom here she's
referring to the redefinition of
marriage
which even even barack obama opposed
like eight or nine years
ago hillary clinton when they ran for
president
they said marriage is a sacred union
between a man and a woman
so this infantry woman
is obviously way more woke than even the
most
left-wing presidents we've had i suppose
until joe biden
now why why is this why are they pushing
this out there
i actually i think i understand the
logic between the
behind the u.s army and the cia pushing
this out they believe we're not going to
fight real wars anymore it's all going
to be propaganda wars it's all going to
be messaging
it's all going to be drip drab drip drab
from the government and foisting that on
the rest of the world
and our most lethal propaganda that we
can put out there is this woke
insanity so they are trying to recruit
people for that
it's the it's the last institution that
hasn't been totally taken over by the
left the military but they're trying to
i think a lot of the officer class has
been
and now they're saying yeah we don't
want guys who look like that crazy
russian
we want super woke girls who are far to
the left of barack obama
who all they want to talk about is their
lesbian mothers
we want them because that that will be
the final institution to fall and
and by the way there is a strategic
purpose here they're very good at
propaganda
they're very very good at prolly
politics on the woke
left does not make us feel very safe
though does it
doesn't make me feel very safe and so
when things are going a little kooky i
think it's very good time to invest in
precious metals
one great way to do that acre gold
physical gold
is expensive right gold bars they're
expensive what if i told you you could
start investing in gold bars
for as little as 30 a month michael
that's not possible
it is possible with acre gold they have
this great program
you pay each month and once your gold
stash reaches the price of their gold
bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house
acre has a new 100 a month subscription
to a five gram gold bar acre
keeps you updated on your gold stash
every month and ships
once you reach the price threshold it's
just
so simple you know looking around now
we've seen gas
lines we've seen inflation going up
it's reminding us of the carter years
and it's reminding us of the 1970s well
physical gold great way to hedge against
all that sort of
inflation and craziness head on over to
getting gold.com noel start investing
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre
that's getakergold.com thank you aker
gold for supporting the show
in this debate here over the woke army
ad
in the woke cia ad for instance
we we compare it to the russian army ad
where it's the crazy guy with the giant
muscles shooting guns and
and we we laugh about that but in our
public discourse you're not really
allowed to suggest there's anything
wrong
with the the woke army ad are you what's
wrong
are you saying it's wrong to redefine
marriage
are you are you a bigot are you a phobe
you must be a
are you saying it's wrong for two
lesbian women to raise a child who knows
whose child it is but are you saying
that's wrong that's somehow
not the same as a husband and a wife
raising a child how dare you
you saying it's wrong that this
girl is fighting in combat are you how
dare you
you're really not allowed i mean i guess
we'll do it on this show for as long as
they let us stay on the air
to suggest huh maybe you know maybe that
isn't ideal maybe they're you know there
are
more ideals ways of of raising children
or fighting wars or but we'll say it but
you're not really allowed to say that at
universities
at the workplace you're not really
allowed to in the government certainly
you're not you're not allowed to say it
anywhere
so much for academic freedom there's
always going to be boundaries on these
things
and by the way it's about to become much
harder to raise questions about this
this is the ideology of drag queen story
hour now throughout the entire culture
remember we were told by all those
squishes all the
quote-unquote conservatives who were
totally cool with drag queen story hour
called it a blessing of liberty
we were told oh it's just a come on just
a little thing it's a little thing at
some library in
san francisco it's no big deal so now
pbs is teaming up with the new york city
department of education they're
partnering up on drag queen story hour
programming uh here is miss little hot
mess
one of the leaders of drag queen story
hour talking about the new venture
which is geared towards kids aged three
to eight get your singing voices ready
and we're gonna start with our hips the
hips on the dry quinoa swish swish swish
swish swish swish swish swish swish
the hips on the drag queen go swish
swish swish
all through the town the
dance of the dragon goes twirl twirl
swirl
to world twirl twirl to world world
twirl
the dance of the dragon goes
to world to world to world
[Music]
all through the town
big finish excellent
give yourselves a round of applause
okay i've had enough round of applause
let's let's that's too much round of
applause
what's wrong with that hey what's wrong
with that
are you are you seriously going to say
it's wrong
for drag queens to be dancing around for
children
you can't say that the new york city
department of education says it's great
pbs
public broadcasting says it's great this
is no longer just in some library your
kids are going to see this
if they're watching pbs which means
you're a bad parent
but let's say they flip you know you're
trying to show them the good stuff
you know you're trying to show them
wholesome entertainment like i don't
know anything else
but then they accidentally turn on pbs
and they see this
this is what's going out there in the
culture and you will not be pro
there is no academic freedom in the
classroom or at work or in the
government
to disagree with this sort of thing
you'll be called a bigot you'll be
called a
phobe of some sort and you will lose
your job and that's just the way it goes
it's not the only thing crazy going on
in new york right now by the way
andrew yang running for mayor of new
york some kind of
imaginative conservatives really
enjoyed andrew yang when he was running
for president i always thought he was
one of the worst candidates in the race
and i was totally right now he's talking
about giving non-citizens the right to
vote
now how can we continue to invest in our
democracy to make it better here in new
york city
i think we should enable young people to
vote
starting at age 16. the second thing we
should do
is expand the franchise to non-citizens
lawful permanent residents now we're
here in part inside the statue of
liberty because new york city
is a city of immigrants i myself am the
some immigrants and
immigrants form the core of so many of
our
neighborhoods and communities there are
approximately 622
000 lawful permanent residents you
probably think of them as green card
holders
who are responsible for
tens hundreds of millions of dollars in
tax revenue
their kids go to our schools they supply
many of the jobs
that we rely upon they should have a say
in the future of their city too
we can enable green card holders lawful
permanent residents
to be able to vote so young people
non-citizens
but we have to invest in the mechanics
of our democracy at a higher level
there it is yang wants to invest in our
democracy he wants to expand
freedom by letting foreign nationals
vote in our elections
now do you see the problem here the
problem that andrew yang is showing you
is the problem
with this this whole abstract notion of
freedom and sometimes you see it
expressed in freedom of speech and
sometimes you
you especially see it expressed in this
like academic freedom canard
it's true in a certain sense by giving
foreign nationals who are in our country
the right to vote you would expand
freedom certainly the freedom of these
foreigners to vote
and you would expand democracy in the
sense that more people would be voting
but by doing that you would be
undercutting freedom and you would be
undercutting democracy
because democracy requires a distinction
between
the citizens and the non-citizens the
people who are in and the people who are
out
the country and not the country that's
the point of national borders which
people like andrew yang are trying to
erase
that that if you're if the citizens are
going to have freedom
you've got to limit the freedom of
non-citizens to interfere in the
citizens government
if the democracy is going to be strong
you need to deny
democratic rights to the people who are
not in the democracy
there is a thought that stops thought
that's the only thought that ought to be
stopped a line from chesterton that
is more and more apt each day
if you want there to be freedom in the
classroom
you need to
limit certain things right if you want
the whole purpose of liberal education
is to teach you how to use your freedom
that's why it's the liberal arts right
it's liberal education to make sense of
our freedom it's not to learn how to do
a trade it's not to learn how to do a
job
contrary to what many conservatives say
about how you've got a major in stem or
whatever
no the point of liberal education is
actually so you can read a bunch of
literature and history
and make sense of human nature and your
freedom and tamp down your vices and
and exercise your virtuous habits and
your your higher will
so in order to do that
you for instance you should not be
taught things that undermine
the notion of objective reality or
goodness or truth or beauty
which is precisely what these radical
leftists are doing
if you want to have true academic
freedom as william f buckley makes very
clear in the book that launched the
modern conservative movement
that must mean the freedom of parents
and trustees and people in in our
political system
to limit the curriculum
people can have look if some kooky
professor like hannah nicole jones
wants nicole hannah i keep confusing her
with anna nicole smith
so nick who's a much more admirable
person than nicole hannah jones
nicole hannah jones if she wants to
teach her kooky trash her
anti-historical nonsense
if she wants to explore that in her own
intellectual pursuits on her own time
and her own dollar that's totally fine
by me i got no problem with that
but she does not have the right to foist
that trash on students in the classroom
particularly
not in a taxpayer funded classroom you
want true freedom
then you got to put limits
on all of that disgusting libertine
garbage
that would undermine freedom this is one
of the themes of my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling mind you can head on
over to speechlessbook.com to pre-order
your copy today or if you want an extra
personal touch
which i would strongly recommend text
speechless to 53445 to pre-order a
signed copy what i would recommend
actually
best of all is you should get three
copies seriously you should get through
i know a lot of you have pre-ordered i
love that that you pre-ordered the book
that's great
you should get that copy to read thumb
through
you should get the signed copy to keep
and i saw keepsake that'd be kind of fun
and you should get the audible you
should get the audio book so that you
can read it in the car
now some people might think that i'm
saying this just so that we can triple
the book sales
well they're sort of right but i
actually do this a lot i will often get
the audio book and the physical book and
then i'll switch back and forth
if you want to understand the pc police
better than they understand themselves
you know what you should do you should
go
pre-order speechless
there we go we'll be right back with the
mailbag
welcome back to the show my first
question comes from
andrew sir knowles i bid the assist for
i am speechless
controlling words controlling minds that
does that count is that does he get a
ding okay i guess he doesn't
i've i thought i thought they got dings
when they but that's okay that's fine we
already got two
i've been very italian for my entire
life but a few weeks ago i heard you use
a presumably italian word that i had
never heard before and could not find
anywhere because i have no idea how to
spell it
the words sounded like ghoul yoon's
or maybe gul unis or youtube captions
spelled it ghoulian
please enlighten me so that word that i
used if you're from new york
if you come from a southern italian
family like sicily or calabria or
monopoly or something like that you
might have heard this term
gulens is a kind of new york
bastardization of a southern dialect of
the italian word
colioni colioni is uh the sort of thing
that
caitlyn jenner once had you know colioni
is the uh
it's like the word cajones is where it
comes from it's a great word
and gullion's just really is a terrific
way to say it i'm glad that i could
teach you
new york italian slang from alexander
michael
you and ben seem to have somewhat
different notions of free speech you
frequently say that not all cancer
culture is bad
for example uh or that is rather
canceling communists
critical race theory proponents etc and
that's good whereas ben seems to take a
somewhat more libertarian free speech
absolutist approach
and often warns of wielding political or
cultural power that you wouldn't want to
be wielded against you if the other
party culture became more dominant my
question is this
how do you strike the ideal balance
between canceling abhorrent ideas
while still maintaining the appropriate
amount of free speech principles thanks
active duty marine a long time fan thank
you very much
i i know that ben talks about this a
little bit you know he
he definitely speaks much more in the
free speech absolutist camp
but i actually don't think our ideas on
this are very far apart
because i think that if you asked ben
hey ben do you think racists should be
canceled
i think he would probably say yes in
fact i think he has said yes
in the past if you asked ben hey if
someone you know says heil hitler at the
water cooler do you think they
should not lose their job i think he
would obviously say yeah no that person
has no right to keep their job
so i think in practice he would he would
acknowledge those limits
and may you know maybe his language
would be a little more in the
free speech abstraction camp than mine
would be but i just think
i think that actually kind of proves the
point right we would all acknowledge
that speech has limits this is true as a
matter of law
right there are certain speeches just
illegal direct threats
fraud intellect copyright infringement
uh sedition these sorts obscenity
obviously so
those sorts of things and the those
protections especially obscenity have
been whittled away over the years
but the point of it is the reason we
have those protections is that some
speech
undermines other speech and so i'm not
even saying
it's great to cancel people i mean i
think it's great to cancel communists i
think it's awesome i think it's great to
cancel nicole hannah jones i'm totally
for that
but it's more than that i i guess i'm
saying
we will cancel people people will be
canceled every society threat all of
history
including and especially our own has
cancelled people
the thing that's changed and it's what
we're referring to now with canceled
culture is just what people get
cancelled for in the 50s you get
canceled for being a communist
today you get cancelled for not being a
communist and so i just
i think that the the real squishes on
this
i'm not talking about ben i'm talking
about people who won't acknowledge that
there are any limits to speech
whatsoever
the real squishes on this are just
burying their head in the sand and just
denying reality and i think
politics goes a lot better for you when
you acknowledge reality
and the reality is there are going to be
standards there are going to be things
that people
face consequences for and get ostracized
for and even are censored for
and i would just much rather those
standards be good and true
than false and wicked like the ones that
the left is trying to push it forward
and we've fallen into the strap for a
long time and it's the the problem that
i'm trying to fix
urgently trying to fix in my upcoming
book speechless
from grace dear michael knowles i'm a
college student next year is my senior
year
i'm going to be a middle school math
teacher it's not a popular age but yeah
it's not good luck for you oh my gosh
you're a saint
but those kids need lots of love and
someone who won't force them into the
leftist lie next year
my college is going to be requiring the
vaccine to attend we'll still be
required to wear masks on campus
i don't want to get the vaccine because
of the stories i've heard about its
effects i've brought up my concerns with
family and close friends
i was offered a chance at a forged
vaccine card because of my faith i feel
as though lying is wrong
and i don't think that people should be
forging vaccine cards do i get the
vaccine and just pray that it does more
harm
it does more good than harm thank you
for your wisdom a suavest of the daily
wire hosts sincerely a concerned college
student
tricky question other people have
written in with this question
if you have very serious concerns about
the vaccine i think it's perfectly right
not to get the vaccine
now there's a question over
how dishonest it would be to imply to
someone that you have had
that vaccine when you have not had that
vaccine and how one might say it without
committing
a sin without lying overtly
but while maybe obscuring
one's real
actions and desires and motives
i think that if you don't want to get
the vaccine that's a perfectly
legitimate thing
i think you're obviously a young person
you're not really at risk of this virus
i think the overreach here is outrageous
by the government
and i don't think that the public health
officials have very much credibility at
all
and i think that there are ways to be
creative in one's language in
communication
that would not require one to commit a
mortal sin while still avoiding this
vaccine
take that for what it's worth from paul
hey michael when speaking to those who
imagine themselves to be a they or
them why are you okay being referred to
as a you
shouldn't we be addressing them as y'all
or you guys for
for example demi when did you guys
decide y'all were non-binary
i want to get this right michael i would
hate to offend someone especially in a
way
they don't yet know is offensive to them
thank you mike i'll have a wonderful
weekend i need
i need a drink after that question i
don't know if i did anybody
well there's another trick too because
when i moved to the south senator cruz
said michael have you started to speak
southern yet and i said
how do you speak southern you said well
instead of referring to you you have to
refer to y'all
i said oh well you'd refer to y'all in
the second person plural right when
you're talking to multiple people he
said no you refer to y'all even when
you're talking to one person
i said well if you call if you refer to
y'all when you're talking to one person
then what is the plural of y'all he said
well it's all y'all well
so i don't know i'm obviously not the
expert on these various dialects i'm
pretty good on southern italian southern
american and woke leftist
a little bit harder for me but i agree
it's very very tricky and
even even the verb agreement is tricky
here if demi lovato is now
they would you say they is demi lovato
their name you say their name is demi
lovato that's not complicated but they
is they goes they goes to the store
now this sounds ungrammatical i guess
it's ungrammatical from the very
beginning
from ken are we coming at the abortion
issue from the wrong perspective it
seems obvious that the left does not
think or care that a fetus is a living
thing with rights should we then switch
the argument
to men's rights to to have a say on what
happens to their unborn child
i was not always a christian in my
younger years there were two times i had
to drive my lady to get an abortion oh
my gosh
oh my and both times i begged her not to
do it
gosh i don't mean to be crass but if
sperm is found on a body or a rape
victim
or a rape victim it's his dna but if
it's used to help create a brand new
life
we're told it's no longer his maybe
changing the minds of the left is the
wrong angle maybe we should change the
minds of the quiet men afraid to speak
up
for their 50 of the decision yeah i mean
fair enough
the issue here gosh what a horrible
thing i'd
very true i mean i have many thoughts on
this experience sorry
sorry that you were involved in that
sorry especially for the kid
should should the man have rights here
uh yeah certainly the man should i mean
we should just outlaw abortion so it's
not
it should not really be even a question
of the men or the women it just should
not be legal
and obviously the men should have some
say here because the
man is one of the parents one of the two
parents of the
little child regardless of what the us
army says about that and lesbian mothers
and all sorts of things
now the problem here though is
if you're having sex out of wedlock
which
statistically everybody is doing so i
you know not
not trying to sound holier than now
because
now i happen to be married you know did
not find myself
in uh in that awful situation uh however
really it is incumbent on the men to
kind of man up and not put women in a
bad position and if they do put women in
a bad position to man up and get married
and not not facilitate these sorts of
awful things but to say hey
let's go shotgun wedding baby we're
getting married in a month or two and i
you know people don't
don't want to do that and maybe it was
just a one-night stand or something but
that's why you
shouldn't do that sort of thing and and
you know if you do a lot of people do it
but then there are going to be
consequences to that and no matter how
awful the consequence of that would be
one imagines it could not be worse than
killing a kid right
so yes men should have greater rights
here but men also need to
behave in a more civilized way and if
they make mistakes they gotta
take responsibility for those mistakes
fr and by the way also
if the mistake is a child if the
consequence of the mistake is a child
it's not a bad reward not a bad reward
for your mistake from matthew hey
michael
i recently turned 19 which is the legal
age to purchase tobacco products where i
live in vancouver canada
oh my gosh canada is freer than america
they raised the age here in the united
states to 21.
when i was a kid it was 18 but now it's
21. oh my gosh that's pathetic
i've been curious to give score smoking
a try with my friends particularly
because our ridiculous provincial health
guidelines still only permit outdoor
gatherings
and i see it as a good way to have
something to do while hanging out
together when i mentioned this to my
mother she was absolutely horrified
doesn't help that when you google our
cigars harmful the top result is a page
from the cdc
that basically says cigar smoking will
turn you into a tooth decaying cancer
magnet
since you mentioned on your show that
you started smoking cigars at an early
age do you think it's a worthwhile habit
to adopt
and convince my mother of if so how
should i go about changing her negative
perception of scores
cigars entail health risks that's just
the case drinking entails health risks
eating fast food intel's health risks
you can mitigate some of this in by do
only doing it in moderation i wouldn't
call it a habit i don't i think of
cigarette smoking as a habit that's
really an addiction that that satisfies
the appetitive part of our
souls uh whereas i i think of cigar
smoking as a hobby
that appeals to the thematic part of our
souls what do i mean by that i mean that
cigarette smoking is just more about
kind of base appetites whereas cigar
smoking is more spirited it's more
of a jubilant activity it's more of a
celebratory sort of thing
and so i you know if i don't have a
cigar for a while i don't start getting
the shakes and scratching my neck
i like i enjoy smoking cigars i had had
one for breakfast as a matter of fact
and a little just a few puffs of one for
breakfast that i didn't finish last
night
but you should be aware there are health
risks okay there's health risks to a lot
of things in life
and so if you do it in moderation i mean
that's what i do and i think it's
terrific
but you know there there is a world in
which you have to face health
consequences for that there's no way to
escape consequences in life i think
there was a line though from churchill
who said that he's taken more out of
cigars than cigars have taken out of him
from mason michael i've got to admit i
look forward to watching your show daily
just to see what outfit you have on
what you're the most wow this is great i
should have put this question further up
in the show
you're the most consistently best
dressed man other than jordan peterson
do you just have good taste or does your
wife help pick your wardrobe
wow to be compared to jordan peterson in
the sartorial department is a great
honor
jordan always wears those wonderfully
tailored seville rose suits
i appreciate the compliment on my taste
i consider myself to be a man
of simple taste i am easily satisfied by
the very best
another line borrowed from winston
churchill from joshua
why is everyone complaining that biden
seemingly didn't get
anything in return for lifting sanctions
on ns2 pipeline
instead of wondering what russia did to
earn it more democrat solicited russian
election interference uh yes of course
there's a ton of shady stuff it was so
preposterous when the left i mean
specifically with regard to russia the
idea that the left would
accuse the right of cozying up to russia
after the left spent
almost a full century sucking up to the
soviet union in some cases working
directly on their behalf
is crazy but yeah there are it's not
just feel-good ideological stuff
there's some brass knuckle money and
power politics behind a lot of this
from sophia michael i watched candace's
show today and her argument with nicole
arbour
reminded me of what you always say about
cancel culture it seems like the right
is indeed confused about what we stand
for
and i think the problem is a semantic
one how we define
cancer culture we should be canceling
celebrities not regular people
who do heinous things online like
harassment right give the libs a taste
of their own medicine except we stand up
for the good the true the beautiful
did you watch the episode what do you
think subscribe for ben stayed for
clavin renewed for knowles thank you i'm
so pleased to hear that
in our final 10 seconds candace was
right
yes canceling is totally fine i mean i
really i like nicole arbour
very very nice gal and but i disagree
with a lot of conservatives on this
as i think i've made clear in this show
people will be canceled there will be
standards
people will face consequences the
question is what for
what are the consequences what are the
things that are acceptable to stay
what are the things that are
unacceptable to say the reason that
we've lost
so much of the culture i think is
because we've thrown our hands up and
disavowed standards entirely
which we continue to do at our own peril
learn how to avoid it
in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show
we'll see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive
producer jeremy boary our technical
director is austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew klavan host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin